[Applaudissements]
véronique lussier et chef d'orchestre à
longueuil depuis quelques mois seulement
d'autres petites elle avait déjà l'air
et la chanson j'ai débuté très tôt la
musique en suivant des cours de piano
violon j'ai fait en chorale également au
secondaire je viens de compléter mon
doctorat direction d'orchestre nos
trentenaires se dit chanceuse de faire
partie d'une génération où les femmes
occupent de plus en plus de place et ça
c'est vraiment une évolution de la
société plusieurs éléments ont fait que
les femmes maintenant ressentent des
possibilités pour exercer un métier qui
étaient traditionnellement exercée par
exemple quand je sentais de la
résistance cernay des femmes des années
que la croix elle dirige d orchestre
depuis 30 ans elle dit que les
mentalités ont évolué de plus en plus de
femmes qui dirigent des jeunes femmes
mais maintenant je dirais que je sais
pas c'est une majorité et puis retiré
que en ce moment c'est très effervescent
et je sais fort bien
même si le chemin pour se rendre au
podium est de plus en plus fréquentée
par les femmes
il est encore très peu au canada on
estime que 14% des chefs et directeurs
artistiques d'orchestre sont des femmes
contre 11% aux etats-unis et 5 % en
français fendant jamais évolué beaucoup
de fun world truck des femmes chefs de
requêtes en en lice le lot dans la donc
même tenait jusque là pour ses critiques
culturels plus leur caisse très
prestigieux - les familles ont accès y'a
pas une femme chef d'orchestre de
laisser un
c'est vrai que les grands orchestres
symphoniques ne s'ouvre pas aussi
facilement je pense aux jeunes
candidates femmes
j'ai encore jusqu'à présent mais en fait
pour être honnête je pense que ça ça ne
s'attendront guerre ces chefs sont
certaines que ce n'est qu'une question
de temps avant de trouver la parfaite
harmonie
et c'est marie laurence dané radio
canada montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]